welcome to this video Mark's bay that's
a new opponent for the channel Kings
Indian no Greenfeld ok I want to try
something near the edge for line looks
funky but it has some dangers for black
so c5 interesting I guess h5 is the idea
so I'm going going with this ok check
check over to h4 funnier threatened
Queen g8 I am amazed how quickly though
some people can play a position that is
so unconventional ok anyway it's a good
move but let's have a look my
development is not exactly great hmm
maybe you three you cannot go Queen to
d7 or something or you form the form
night beef night before is an annoying
really at a guess take with the bishop
okay this is I mean slower than slow but
night before is also rather knowing and
maybe g4 wasn't move I him it's
interesting pawn takes is also very
interesting trying to get a brook
quickly to the D file because he has
some problems to ass or disposition and
let's do that okay but should be three
as in the mix but I have 93
performed g1 young that's a big threat
yes um so Shep g51 night already 92 just
directly going for this no it's not easy
for him if I do this I think Bishop
probably has to drop back otherwise as
Queen g8 Queen f7 which she ignores okay
I'm used I'm used to that being ignored
and chest check okay and let's grab this
born yeah I have no development but
everything else is great his king is
wandering around so the shop g bishop i
watch or i mean like g3 Bishop g2 or you
form i would love to get something in
like night c4 and possible Bishop f4
it's hard to look that night though
still efore less 95 maybe it's really
better to to not move pawns and not
weaken efore would weaken d3 for example
95
yeah I have to be careful about the time
that's the biggest danger in this
position some wacky time time situation
happening so is going over there and
still cannot cannot move easily Queen
Queen back twin c4 or something and then
be sure before very rigid position not
even sure this is a move actually it's
got night f51 what happens if i play
actively on my own it looks kind of
wrong but ok it's king is also not very
secure red ruby to as an option may be
ok too ok Queen here I guess
currently I don't change this soooo king
nah come on I don't get it queen is six
I always have clean be seven I mean that
that I don't believe at all check be
sure before i am moving the king should
be three losers but this isn't that
working I'm threatening queen bee seven
queen queens is six and some person is
some kind of made so
one minute 14 very slow here don't see a
real maid somehow i can do to e5 all the
way yeah but i can can also take here
check take here check take even take c5
that's funny I can oh no he's going back
I can trade queens now on it's time are
you mate can give this chick it's better
my ideas Quincy five Quincy three and
just um black resigns yup everything and
the engine even find some kind of meat
but it was a wiki game yeah but I think
I did exactly what the idea is of this
agelessness irritate the hell out of
black with the Queen comin even though
this is a very strange position and this
is what I don't get how can you play in
this position is like super
unconventional how can you play this
move in one second this is just wrong I
know it's a common theme in my channel
people hate me for saying that but it is
wrong yeah what you have to do is think
at least a little bit yeah I mean your
king is no I also played this year
rather quickly but it is that idea of
white set up and well here I mean for
example here you can do this which is an
interesting idea threatening on c2 there
are a couple of options ok anyway there
should be six and now I went a 3 which
is kind of kind of firm kind of cheeky
but not before engine gives now King 27
without clear edge for black just
stepping out
now it's difficult to develop this is
very good for black according to stock
fish yeah it's it I cannot develop
really I had my doubts but this is a
thing is helpful yeah that that turns
everything to an advantage for white
Bishop f4 also was interesting but I
like this idea just grab this porn and
let him show what the compensation is g3
back and this is a that's a very brutal
move and something that I'm completely
unsure about that was good at least it
is very very sharp 95 was his choice and
now he gave it away with 93 and the
computer gives King p8 with a clear
advantage of black mm-hmm this is the
problem is the problem is I mean my
development is not great and if i take
he he now has just for real yeah and
yeah I'm he I'm losing its the tech is
enormous and I have to go back now and
there is no way I don't get any counter
playing and since King position mm-hmm
no no definitely check okay check oops
check your check over right check check
check yeah I would have just taken
material I have to admit but the end
gives check this lauren has made check
check okay this is actually also the
chance I cannot escape check check check
check mate nice goodnight meet okay that
was a wacky game with some some soft
spot thanks for watching